hey 42 here you can now purchase real
vegan cheese which is synthetic milk
free cheese created using strands of
human DNA welcome to RIT your lips
appear red or pink not because the skin
is a different color but because the
skin is thinner than normal and you are
actually seeing the underlying blood
vessels through the skin it took the
inventor of the Rubik's Cube a whole
month before he was able to solve the
cube for himself before dummies were
invented human corpses were used for
craft tests instead of hiring gardeners
Google uses 200 goats for mowing their
large amount of grass at their
headquarters a recent study published in
the journal Psychological Science found
that posting an image of a dish to
Instagram before eating it can make it
taste better the great school of
wizardry in California is the first
wizard school to be officially
recognized as an academic establishment
in 2005 a man named Ronald McDonald
actually robbed a Wendy's the average
human being gets through nine hundred
skins in a lifetime there are more
people speaking French in Africa than in
France in Japan Ronald McDonald is known
as Donald MacDonald to make
pronunciation easier for the Japanese
the youngest known person to ever be
divorced was only ten years old
to disguise dead passengers during a
flight British Airways used to give them
sunglasses a vodka and tonic and a copy
of the Daily Mail to avoid being caught
on film by a speed camera
you would have to be traveling at 28,000
miles per hour two-thirds of the world's
population has never seen snow I've
melted down for scrap a bronze medal
from the London 2012 Olympic game would
be worth less than three pounds
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2